We are back again, ready to improve our
car and fix some very annoying problems.
This time, we'll give the car shape gas
wheel so it can go as smoothly over
bumps, fix lighting ramps and lateral
collisions, and many more improvements.
But before we start, let's do something
that we should have done a long time
ago. Changing the physics engine.
Starting from Gordo 4.6, Jolt physics is
now going to be the default physics
engine. So, there is no reason not to
use it anymore. So, if you are on good
4.5 or higher, go to project settings
and under physics 3D, change the physics
engine to jolt. And after a quick
restart, we should now be getting a much
more precise and faster physics
calculation. Just like that. Then we'll
open the wheel script and rename a few
variables. Here I'll be changing the
velocity variable to speed when it's a
non vector value. So, we have the car
forward speed at the top
and the wheel forward speed used at the
bottom. Now things should be hopefully
less confusing. And another important
thing before we start the direction
indicator we are using from global basis
are not normalized.
So if your raycast node or any of its
parents are scaled, you'll be getting
completely wrong values for all your
calculations.
If you want to make sure to get correct
values, you can add a normalized at the
end on lines that use the global basis
vector. But I'll leave that to you. And
just one last thing, if you remember
previously, we had to disable the recast
node and manually call force recast in
the code to prevent the precision error
caused by delay checks. But while this
works, we lose the book shapes in game.
So I figure a proper way to make it
work. First, select all the rcast and
enable them back. And to make sure we
get the correct results, open the
process tab and set the physics priority
to minus one. This will make the nodes
execute last and fix the precision
problems without the manual request. But
now, let's really start. The first
outstanding problem with the car is
ramps. The car simply won't stay still
on them. You can hold the brake all you
want and it will still slide down. Not
good. Even if we set the traction to one
and hold the brake, it still slides.
Something is definitely wrong here. So,
let's reset this value and get to work.
Open up the wheel script. And in the
spring calculation, we are going to take
this spring force and save it into a
variable named suspension force before
we apply the collision normal. And now
at the very bottom, after all the forces
are done being calculated, we are going
to apply a counter spring force to
nullify some of these spring forces in
the X and Y directions, but only when
the car is at a very low speed. So let's
check if the wheel speed is low enough
with ABS float F speed and choose a
small value. You can adjust this value
or turn it into a variable later.
Then we are going to get the suspension
force in the car Y-axis.
And then reduce the final Z force Z
force based on how in line it is with
the global Y vector 3.up. Copy this line
and do the same for the X force.x next.
And by countering the spring forces this
way, we can make the car stop at low
inclines, but it still very slowly
slides down. So we are going to add
another check just before the Z force
calculation. Now we are going to set the
friction to a very high value if the car
is moving at a low speed. This can be a
very low value and it will work kind of
like a static friction for our simulated
wheels.
But now our car perfectly stopped on
ramps and you can set the friction check
speed to a very low value just to stop
that extra momentum. And it still works
the same successfully stopping the car.
And of course it won't work on bigger
ramps. because we still have to fight
gravity and our counter force is based
on how aligned the car is with the up
direction. Now with the ramp problems
fixed, let's start turning the wheels
into shape casts. If you remember
previously, one of the big hurdles of
raycast cars are small gaps. This is due
to raycast being a single array and
failing to detect gaps. So to fix this,
we'll turn our wheels into shapes and
sweep an area for collisions. Instead of
replacing the gray cast wheels, we'll be
adding the shape cast as an alternative.
So, we can turn it on and off depending
on the type we want to use. So, let's
select our first wheel and create a
shapecast 3D node. Just make sure it is
not the first child because the script
used that for the mesh. Next, create a
cylinder shape or if you don't care for
precision that much, using a sphere will
give you much better results while being
faster to calculate. But, we'll use a
cylinder here.
Set the height to 0.2 how thick the tire
is. And let me change the debug color to
red so we can better see what we are
working with. Now, as you might have
noticed, the cylinder is facing the
wrong way and it will sweep the shape in
this direction.
So, let's set the target to zero for now
and rotate the shape cast in the Z-axis
by 90° to turn it in the correct way and
set the radius to 0.33.
Now, it's important that the shape cast
is at its origin or a lot of things will
break. if you need to adjust the shape
cast position. Make sure you're doing so
by moving the raycast node above. So
let's reset the position for the shape
cast node and not forget to set the
physics priority to minus one so we
don't get precision errors. But because
we rotated the shape cast now the target
position Y is sideways. So we will have
to remember we need to adjust our X
position instead. Make sure that minus X
goes down which might be flipped in case
you rotated the wheels the other way
around. And for better performance, you
can adjust the max results to three or
some low number. And I will increase the
radius to 0.35 just so we can see the
shape debug over the wheels.
Now copy the shape cast node and paste
it inside all the other car wheels. They
should all be already in the correct
position, which means it's time to start
coding.
First, let's create an export variable
for the shape cast node. I'll put it at
the top.
And now we need to assign each shape
cast to its wheel.
Next, inside the ready function, we are
going to check if we have a shape cast.
If we do, we need to adjust its target
position much like our raycast node
above. But we are changing the X here
because we rotated the node. And the
shape cast doesn't need the wheel radius
anymore because the shape itself has it.
And finally, we need to call shapecast
addex exception and give it the parent
node, the car's widget body, so it
doesn't detect collisions with the car
body. Then in the wheel physics you
modify the pass condition. If you are
not using the shape cast and the ray
cast is not colliding we don't
calculate. And if you are using the
shape cast and the shape cast is not
colliding we don't calculate forces.
Then for the contact point if the shape
cast exists we set the contact point be
the shape cast get collision point0.
There can be more than one collision
point at once but usually getting the
first one already gives us a very good
result. If you want to calculate the
forces for all the collision points, you
need to create a loop and get the sum of
the spring forces for all points and not
forget to divide the final suspension
force by the total number of collision
points. But we won't do that. Then right
at the end of the suspension force
calculation, if we are using shape cast,
we need to use shapecast.get collision
normal.
And just like that, the car will now
gracefully go over bumps and behave much
more naturally.
And let's not forget to set the shape
cast target at the start of the physics.
So we can change the sprinkl length at
runtime if you need to. But we are not
done yet. There are a few hidden
problems with this yet. First, cylinders
are not great. Besides being expensive
to calculate, the collision point that
is hitting the ground is a bit
imprecise. If you take a look at this
other car that has bigger tires, we can
see why. The collision point in the
ground is alternating between the left
and right. This usually won't cause much
problems, but just know that this can
happen. Another problem is that the
collision point we are getting the green
sphere is not at the bottom of the
wheel. So when we calculate the distance
from the rest position to get the spring
length like we were doing with the
reccast before we might get slightly
wrong values. We can fix this by
calculating the red point instead with a
bit of extra math. But the difference is
usually not significant enough to
notice. So we will leave it as it is.
Now the other problem is this. We can
get our wheel stuck inside the ground
fairly easily. In this situation, the
shape cast is not detecting any
collisions anymore. So, no forces are
being applied there. But if you move a
bit, it might just be enough for it to
work again. Not great. And it is fairly
easy to get this problem. Any high
enough jump will get you stuck with
this.
So, why is that? Well, shape cast won't
properly detect things already inside
them. Only objects that are hit after
they have moved. If you take a look at
the car and push it down, you can see
the tire shape is pushed down at its
most extended position. Although this
gives us the correct collision point,
there are situations that the things
just break and stop detecting at all. So
to fix this, we are going to create a
new variable called shape cast offset of
0.3. We are going to use this to push
our shape cast above its rest position
without altering the calculations. We
just need to subtract the offset inside
the target position calculation
and set the shape cast position. height
to be the offset. This will push the
shape cast to be above its normal
position, meaning it will be harder for
the shape cast to fail due to starting
inside objects. You can play around with
this value to find what works best for
each car. But now, if we push the car
down again, we can see the shape cast
stays correctly in place above the
ground.
And indeed, now we have working shape
cast wheels and our little jeep doesn't
get stuck anymore.
But before we finish, there is still
another big problem with our code. Let's
drive this car and take a closer look at
the wheels grip curve values. So far,
everything seems normal. We have a
variable grip similar to the real cars.
But when we come to a slow lateral slip,
we see a problem. Our car doesn't seem
to want to stop and our extraction graph
is maxed out, giving us zero traction
until we move again and it suddenly goes
back to normal. And it's even worse if
the car is hit from the sides. It just
starts moving without any resistance.
Well, while cornering forces are
simulating real forces, we don't
simulate any real art the wheels might
have. So, when the car is moving
sideways, we have a very high sleep
angle and get very little forces back
depending on the grip curve. To fix
that, we are going to do something very
similar to the ramp solution. So, right
after the grip factor is calculated, we
are going to check if the car forward
speed is low enough.
And if it is, we force the grip factor
to zero, meaning there will be a lot of
force and stop the car from moving. And
just like that, now our car behaves more
normally. We can take a hits from the
side. And sliding to a slow stop will
now properly stop the car.
But before we finish the video, let's
make some minor improvements and changes
to the code. First, inside the car
script, let's update the get point
velocity formula to take into account
the center of mass of the car. Change
the global position here to two global
center of mass. Now our point velocity
should be correct even when we are using
a custom center of mass.
Next, let's add a new property for the
wheel called max spring force. This can
be helpful if the car we have has long
suspensions to better customize the
behavior we want. Then inside the
suspension force, we just need to clamp
this value between our max spring force.
So now by customizing this value we can
avoid our car jumping around if the
springs are suddenly compressed. This is
a bigger problem for rakas cars since
they can have the spring qu from zero to
max compression in an instant. But it is
still a good setting to have.
And finally another problem for high
suspension cars. When our jeep go over
the ball the wheel reacts like it should
avoiding the ball but the rigid body
ball is non the wiser and stays in
place.
If you want to fix that, you can go to
the very bottom of the wheel code and
loop over the shape cast collision
points. If the collided object is a
rigid body 3D, just apply a reaction
force. Here I am just using the negative
some forces of the wheel, but you can
fine-tune that later. Now the jeep can
go over objects and fling them around.
And finally, we have a code we can
remove. When using raycast, we
interpolated the wheels position to give
us better results. But shapecast usually
don't have this problem. So you can
increase the value or remove this
entirely.
But that's really it. We have a shape
cast car now along with tons of other
improvements and fixes to make it
finally more stable. As always, if you
would like support me, you can get the
project source files and experiments by
supporting me on Patreon. Now you can go
and customize your car to your own
needs. I hope you like this video and
until next time.